okay okay paper I took my second Baba
and we're playing this weird game called
dinner with house okay yeah Adderley I
want to say let's just say what it's
about English a German top - so - psyche
English okay welcome mr. Webb mr. Brown
I was like already waiting Freya it will
find you in the office down the hallway
and thank you very much sir and have a
pleasant stay sir and I just called you
sir okay
contracts Butler hello sir
Wow weird weird game I'm just seeing it
like a child's work real quick and I
can't go in that room can I just like go
no I guess I can't go the office and mr.
Brown Oh mr. Brown when you're actually
an owl but you did you have a nice house
huh are you okay I'm fine thank you mr.
Webb
you're like hungry though business can
wait until tomorrow
Wow but before we ate we have to meet
the other guests here now guess I'd like
to introduce to you miss April Merritt
April is my business partner mr.
Christian web that nice to meet you
the pleasure there bro but don't you
think it's quite odd that he's in a what
what are you going to say this is her
daughter Josie
uh-huh sir and you already met my Butler
Declan over that horrible night okay all
right well guys what's going on here now
what's happening yeah no no pal you know
delicious it I got to tell you for an
owl pretty good meal Declan you realize
I passed himself he said he's not even
being able to eat Jesus and what do you
think mr. Webb uh it's a pretty good it
did
you know I'm not going to miss track
from the foot that be a crime glad to
hear that there's nothing better than I
got dinner I'm more interested in why
you're an owl you so everyone finished
why can't I say he's an owl yes my oh
god mr. Webb to his room then should I
stay here with mr. Brown I'll be right
back okay we'll see each other tomorrow
mr. Webb okay Chris Klug my office when
you're ready a lot of work to do
you got that right
your room is upstairs second door on the
left
I'll try with mr. Brown what they drunk
them in my hair us why should I speak
out what is because it's very dangerous
that prevail can oh yeah an owl or
dangerous seem to be very aggressive and
he has been it but he's been in the past
do you want to leave this place of
course I do
let's go that he's with Josie right now
you won't leave without her I'm just
gonna get her what can I do to stop us
you're on our side mr. Brown Oh
the only before you fall under it
that okay day - then you don't mess with
the owl you know mr. Declan I'm Thursday
you're wearing my shows well you just
saw so umbrella stand
I made an umbrella at the moment I set
your soft touch anything arrow quick at
least make sure I'll have to go to the
right getting over there he's gone now
okay am I crazy or is that the only
thing I click on let it give the
documents to myself can I go that office
oh yeah okay ah that's word on the why
idea again why I am si web a good
morning nice to see you
I just hand over the contracts and get
straight to work you got it buddy
you made me no but was you took my
language that's a okay enough word
enough we're making good progress here
okay say a letter at dinner say they're
back I can I can you toss her mr. brown
nothing can't find any sleep at night I
could observe the stars to my tells go
okay I'll see each other at dinner
are you crazy coke let's get a dinner
where which way is dinner string an
umbrella mr. mr. Declan the butler how
may I be of service would you recommend
to drink I've got a decent selection of
red wine just don't drink the tap water
why shouldn't I well the water has areas
of that line me what's it gonna today
porridge I love that I ask you a
personal question Declan certainly sir
we were said about quitting a job excuse
me do you think about labor in this
house it's not that I say I'll take care
of it but I need your help
what should I do can you provide some
set a weapon don't play them as my
kitchen I shut down may write tomorrow
this place so at the 8:10 I know
and you got it sir I was working so I
was a tough negotiating partner oh yeah
bet I am mr. owl but I'm confident that
we can conclude an agreement I find a
solution for our problem very good mr.
Christian web snake a your only chance
Christian atheist but okay I'll be over
sent I'm afraid it may be too late
great ah mr. Brown I'm going to work on
something different at the moment please
come back again later first you look at
this telescope okay weird but that's
fine what you came playing mr. Howell
with your game plan oh great mr. Webb
what are you up to uh you just yeah here
mr. Brown out Declan I didn't do
anything wrong sir it's may other sides
about that council eyewear method dinner
no sir place yeah weird weird here it is
Thank You Declan we prefer to leave the
house in I hope so mr. Webb oh say
letter I'm trying to get to the brows
then
I thought I can sell that
and can read at
that crap that now
see you stank up again
okay I just extend them what else I try
to have
Oh what happens now
it's dead
that was well disgusting what's gonna
happen now let's get out of here can we
Lillian anomaly
I think it's very too late for him take
his that mean chaise the owl
oh you have failed me I'm so fair stay
let's have dinner okay
I like mr. Ali plan was office in the
hallway thank you very much was exchange
familiar like I remember for a weird
long forgotten past
okay well okay looks like we're able
merit this amirite chose a hello sir
okay so he's doing a loop until we
forgot the right path I got a case he is
gone too bad
we got to figure out how to get rid of
this just step it out where is he wait
the next day I have to talk to this guy
real quick
like that dang dinner wow this is pretty
interesting game okay you have to hide a
knife in the umbrella stand that is sir
at CERN Shh what's the heck
what's that hackers done ah okay I will
skip this side what the heck is that
tough negotiating after dinner
it's very too late yeah
you can't show up right here better not
okay so I got two knives so I put one
knife and umbrella stand
and then I use one to kill him yes
stupid ow
be prepared to perish actually
transformed out right
he's an eternity I'll about let's get
back I know I've seen this if I and uh
that's have dinner okay day seven
mr. Dyer there goes another
I'm gonna pop this sucker right now
honey
oh yes mr. owl how's it going admitted
okay what am I going to be able to
status did
okay okay let's just pop them
okay I got the knife
yes stupid sucker I got you good didn't
I
just stupid sucker if I could just be an
owl ha and take orders it's like she
could be a boss to a human man being an
owl with your stupid stupid telescope
let's get out of here attack you got to
be kidding me
I got him nice and early
mr. chambers
listen chambers take the contracts take
it great can I say okay great mr. owl I
must add dial I can gather Neath the gas
yeah this is April
this is daughter Josie Wow let's out
then I thank God
okay
um have I got night
okay he lurks he lurks is you missing
out see missing
hey hey I got here hi good morning mr.
chai - there you go
well the guys I see at dinner okay what
does I just burn it
no holy crap was that because I tried to
burn the contracts
what the heck's of that okay mr. Doyle
did you did you see that I was turning
is a now there oh my god I'm turning
full out here help help
I presented today
okay I don't think I'm knife
that's the hack so I need to take the
NIH's okay lesser Declan
everyone who stays here longer than a
few hours falls under spell
okay so this guy is a diver
it's going to sing run again
step 1
okay
can I put a second - yeah you say
what the heck
it is a glitch
I got your stupid contracts answer your
stupid contracts oh my god did I just
glitch out okay I just glitched
okay okay it is again but seriously can
I just got like immediately
anyway shawshank redemption' shank oh
okay good that's too late for him
okay how do I get that knife like really
soon though
okay day 12
she says
okay let me just see if I can walk to
him right away
okay so I can get the knife for the
cruise soon
okay yeah seven I just sang for my know
great
I can't hand over the contracts
yeah but yep like that a little go to
work time for dinner
okay she's going to sing for me again
now
for that today
[Music]
all right
oh my god
see Mustangs are my now I guess singing
is over okay
okay here's the plan legs you can't have
and we do it swiftly all right stupid L
I know crazy now
okay turn the alley up yeah
ah who has forgiven money not again
he sent up too many times okay here we
go
give me that stupid knife
stab them just stab them any like that
mr. chambers like that
that's how you this case you want to tan
tonight longer so I took some Mira
variations
[Music]
don't know Wow okay that was really
weird otherwise thanks for watching
y'all thank ya